aquí tenemos la serie infinita uno más
uno entre dos sobre cinco más uno entre
3 sobre 5 y así sigue y sigue y sigue y
se mantiene por siempre y además podemos
escribir lahm como la suma desde n igual
a uno hasta infinito de uno entre n
elevado a la quinta potencia y luego
luego puede reconocer que cuando n vale
1 tengo 1 entre 1 a la quinta lo cual es
uno de este número de aquí y así nos
seguimos ahora bien puedes darte cuenta
que esta es una p seria una pecera vista
de una forma general se ve como la suma
desde n igual a 1 hasta infinito de 1
entre n elevado a la p donde pep es un
número mayor que 0 así que en este caso
en particular nuestra pe para nuestra
serie es igual a 5 pero es igual a 5
ahora también debes de reconocer que
existen condiciones para que una pc con
verja o diversa voy a escribirlo
convergen sin p es mayor que
que es claramente este escenario que
tenemos aquí p mayor que 1 y divergen
sin pep por una parte es mayor que algo
y por otra parte va a ser menor o igual
que uno y p tiene que es el mayor que
cero porque va a ser una p positiva cero
es menor que per menor o igual que uno
en este caso divergen así que por
ejemplo si esto fuera 0.9 o tres cuartos
entonces la serie en definitiva diver
jería pero en este caso va a converger
entonces déjenme poner esta es una serie
convergente muy bien y hagamos uno más
bien aquí tenemos este 10 cm
tengo un 1 más 1 entre la raíz de dos
más uno entre la raíz de tres y así nos
mantenemos y si observas tengo de nuevo
una p serie la puedes reconocer esta es
la suma infinita desde n igual a 1 está
infinito de 1 entre n y observa abajo
tenemos la raíz de 2
3 la raíz de 4 es decir estamos elevando
a ese número a la potencia en medio
entonces me queda 1 entre n elevado a la
potencia un medio observa que cuando en
es igual a 1
tengo un hombre entre 1 a la un medio lo
cual es simplemente una cuando n vale 2
tengo 1 / 2 elevado a un medio lo cual
es uno entre la raíz de 2 y así seguimos
y seguimos bueno observa que en este
caso tendremos una p serie donde pep es
positivo pero que vale un medio que vale
un medio así que observa en este caso 0
es mayor que pe que es menor o igual que
1 y recuerda la serie divergen es
divergente cuando 0 es menor que p
menor o igual que uno que es claramente
el caso que tenemos un médium está entre
0 y 1 entonces en este caso vamos a
tener una serie divergente